video went viral of a Tick-Tock
influencer describing her encounter with
a man on the Streets of San Francisco
and they just got groceries I'm walking
out of the store
guys walking
stupid and he spits in my face that's
all over my face
then I say excuse me did you just spit
in my face and he says move or I'll rape
you there's also people everywhere and
everyone's just walking by because
they're like I can't handle something
else in San Francisco it's always
something else I don't even know why I'm
posting this that's also why it is at
this point very hard for me to have
sympathy for the typical San Francisco
resident who has this kind of typical
San Francisco experience these are
almost every case liberals who vote for
leftist candidates who promise to make
their communities less safe they vote
for this they choose it they literally
ask for it and then they get what they
asked for
my capacity for pity has I confess
limits and residents of San Francisco
live outside of those limits at this
point